who uh i saw you and uh
king vaughn had a discussion about the
best bay area rappers ever
yeah me and bobby had it who's your top
five
um
e40 number one
we could put it of course
yeah number one to me i think he the
winner of all winners period um
definitely too short yeah um
number three i'm gonna go with the jacka
okay
that was my big bro um number four i'm
gonna go with fad okay fab like
fab is really the mayor of oakland by
the bay area like he could go anywhere
people respect them and he got some
records that's classics
uh number five
keep the snake cake yeah i'm gonna go
keep i respect it yeah no matt dre
now i'm a dre that people always
vallejo i love valet but they get on my
ass about this all the time
i always say to my friends who are from
the bay
i think mac dre is overrated no no no
i'm never gonna say that i say it shout
out to kilo no not about people listen
all i said is no no no from somebody who
did not live in the bay and and and the
music was not important to me like it is
to everybody else obviously feeling
myself and there's records that are i
get it but in terms of like
the way y'all hold mac dre up there no
we hold them up there
being somebody who's not from there yeah
i'm just like
all right so so the thing with dre is
he had his core fans right which was
like everyday people right
it necessarily wasn't in like like the
blackest
times if i could say that like it was
more like latinos and white people
like training shows he always had the
crazy [ __ ] artwork yeah yeah like
those was like
popping things and [ __ ] like that was
that [ __ ] you know black people kind of
just iffy on drugs at first so
the side shows and all that let's keep
this neat nobody out did keep for side
shows and the jack of hager on all of
them records
so drake kind of like caught the win
unfortunately right before he died and
when he died
so dre never even got to perform
filling myself in all those records he
never got to fully feel
what
what he means to the babe like today
because like now nowadays
yeah like he didn't like you know i feel
like um
in the same way that pock never probably
got to really feel what he meant until
you know once he passed i think people
yeah like when people did they bait
chris brown and then drake they probably
would have been bringing dre out right
but like he didn't get to see like his
biggest songs he wasn't here for stretch
told me like he passed away like
a month before the album dropped right
after the album dropped so a lot of that
stuff is like
legendary [ __ ] that he never even got he
never even got to see the results of
yeah he never got to perform at like a
summer jam or you know what i'm saying
like he didn't get to shut down an arena
right right right right everything was
more trivia but now dre is definitely
you know he definitely dope up i'm
talking about when i grew up in oakland
like these was the five people peak
hyphy era before i before it was even a
hyphy when it was just yo keep the sneak
hyphy did you think cause if you think
of like um my ghetto report card
being like the biggest hyphy album
but at the time wasn't 40 not really
considered a hyphy artist
you know 49 40 like the winner that they
just live through all of our moments
yeah 40 is like uh
timeless in terms of like
every time he puts an album out it's
[ __ ] fire and it doesn't matter how
what era we're in
he adjusts he gets the right features
it's crazy but in terms of like my
ghetto report card
like because i feel like the hyphy
movement was something that was like
very uh
grassroots
i guess you're really fully appreciated
you had to live there
my get a report card was like
it took the [ __ ] to a whole another it
was the perfection of it it was crazy
because it took it took it to like such
a crazy level that like you know
[ __ ] tell me when to go is a record you
could play
[ __ ] in brooklyn you know whatever
you know what i'm saying you know i
think 40 was just like he the winner of
all time so he was able to dabble he
could do whatever he wants and be and
make it the the best quality of it
like if it could have been and he had
little john on that like yeah exactly
like the price is such the winner that
he can polish it right you know like d
lo noho was unmixed
it sounds like it a classic right yes it
says but like if 40 had it would have
been mixed a little john for doing right
it would have been even major dilo's
another one of those guys from the bay
who is a big deal but you know is
somebody who's
maybe their potential wasn't seen
nationally
if that makes sense yeah but you never
should go on the stage after if you're
performing no he's crazy he did my
birthday party one year in phoenix and
it was [ __ ] crazy it's hard to
perform at the d-lo in the bay yeah like
he got probably like four certified
records that's like the bay in general's
got songs that like didn't work anywhere
else for like artists not from the bay
yeah that are [ __ ] huge there we the
b-side capital it's crazy yeah they take
pride in that though like what's the
mike jones song flossing flossing jesus
christ is mike jones flossing it's uh
young dro high five mm-hmm
uh
birdman out the ghetto
like this [ __ ] like when you when you
play they go like why you playing this
[ __ ] but out there
yeah like then they're like oh [ __ ] we
probably should have did this [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying so we like to be
b-side capital though why do you think
that is
my bad we probably think we all and ours
at some point yeah you know what i'm
saying like because well i think it for
me it originated like
before the hyphy movement like the
original side shows
it almost used to be like what's the
coolest song you can play that nobody
knows like let me find something on the
album yeah like you have because we know
the singles gonna get played but let me
find this other joint it'd be like a
[ __ ] coming down the street in the van
fo 15 slapping the gap being outstanding
in the middle of a bunch of gangsters
runs in or guapalay closer like that
it available yeah yeah yeah yeah so we
big on that b
the b sides